哈喽 大家好 欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营
今天我们来讲一下第七课 店铺保证金的认知
那么我们把最容易搞混的店铺保证金和活动保证金彻底讲明白
不管是新手开店还是老商家的活动
这两个保证金的规则都直接关系到了您的钱包和店铺权益
所以接下来的话一定要认真听
首先啊 咱们要明白一个点
就是这两个保证金其实是完全独立的两笔钱
它们不管是从用途 解冻规则 还有金额都是不一样的
所以千万不要把这两者混为一谈
那么我们先说一下保证金的定义
我们保证金的话就是向平台缴存的资金
用以保证商家提供优质的商品和服务
还有一点规则呢就是出现违规情况时是用于向
用户进行赔付和赔偿平台的损失或者承担其他违约责任用的
那我们先说一下店铺保证金吧
就是相当于咱们在拼多多开店的入场券押金
那只要我们想正常运营店铺就必须要交这笔钱
而且呢这笔钱的金额是按照类目来划分的
我们基础的保证金的预值为500元
具体的话您的类目是交多少钱
我们是可以在商家后台 账户资金 保证金进行查看
路径的话就是通过这个路径可以查看到
我们基本上大部分类目比如说服饰啊 家居日用啊等等
最低的话500块钱就可以
像普通的企业店铺类目是1000块钱起
如果是有一些特殊类目比如说食品 美妆
或者是3C数码 身鲜可能会缴纳更高的钱
那这里的话其实是有一个小技巧的
足额缴纳保证金是可以提升我们店铺的基础权重
平台会给到更多的流量倾斜
比少缴纳的店铺可能会更容易起量
所以新手不用一开始就去充很高的金额
可以先按照我们的利目交最低档
等到盈利后或者是店铺的营业额放大了以后
再进行补缴也是可以的
那么我们在这里的话是建议商家缴纳1000块钱以上
那我们如果不缴纳店铺保证金的话
会对我们的店铺有什么影响呢
首先我们是无法建立推广计划的
大家都知道
现在的店商基本上的平台流量都是来源于付费推广
所以如果不能去建立推广计划的话
我们的店铺其实是很难有订单产生的
那第二点呢就是会限制我们发布虚拟商品及其他需要额外保证金的商品
那第三点我们店铺可用资金小于300元的时候
成团订单总金额不超过2500元
这个是对我们店铺的一个限制
那第四点就是成团订单不能超过100单
或者是我们的提现不可以超过三次
包括店铺的违规次数也不能超过两次
店铺的违规订单总订单金额是不能超过10单的
像这些都是不缴纳保证金对我们店铺的一些影响
那有些客户会问
我们缴纳这个钱以后
我们这个钱还能够退回吗
这里的话告诉大家一点
是确定是可以退回的
但是它退回是需要有一定的条件
第一点的话
我们是需要把所有贷处理的订单售后都进行清空
在没有未处理订单
没有未发货订单
没有任何的售后纠纷以及店铺没有违规记录的情况下
这个时候我们去申请退店
那么我们平台呢就会给到30天的一个监测周期
这个30天监测周期过了以后呢
这笔钱就是可以退回的
还有一种方式
是就算不退店的话只要店铺的运营是稳定的正常的没有任何异常也能申请解冻
把解冻的保证金变成可用的余额提现
那这里需要有一个重点提醒
就是退保证金的时候啊
银行卡的信息必须和入住时的信息是一致的
不然的话会导致金额延迟到账甚至退不出去
之前我们就有遇到过有商家因为填错了对公的账户信息
白白多等了半个月
那么接下来说完店铺保证金了以后啊
我们要去介绍一下活动保证金
活动保证金这笔钱它不是强制交的
只有我们的链接想要去报名平台特定的活动
比如说秒杀，九块九特卖或者是竞价像这些的话
它才会需要我们去缴纳活动保证金
所以活动保证金是准入活动的硬门卡
如果没有缴纳或者是不足额直接是没有办法去进行报名的
所以活动保证金它是能够确保平台确保我们商家遵守活动规则
比如说不擅自换品不虚假宣传
能够保证我们在活动产生的订单按时发货
那如果要是违规了的情况下
平台就会从活动保证金里面扣钱赔付给消费者或者是用以赔偿平台的损失
那在2026年的最新规则里面我们的活动保证金分成四个档那第一个档的话是准入门槛最低标准是2000块钱
它能够参加的商品额度是一个额度就是比如说一条链接
它覆盖的秒杀 净价9块9还有月卡都是可以用的那B档的话就是5000块钱
它能够参加两条链接的活动那C档就是2万那像这个档位的话
如何选择呢?我们虽然说平台给大家下放的限额是2000块钱就可以去参加了
但是我们还是建议如果想去玩活动的是至少缴纳5000块钱
那还包括一些大的链接想去参加一些大型秒杀,想去上万人团
基本的话它就是得交到2万块钱才能去参加这样的一些大型门槛的秒杀活动
那很多商家会问了,比如说我交了店铺保证金,报名
活动的时候还需要再交活动保证金吗?答案肯定是需要的,刚刚在前面的话我已经强调过了,两者是独立核算,相互不抵扣的
比如说你店铺是普通类目,交了1000块钱,但是你现在想报名秒杀的话,就得单独再交2000块钱以上,或者是5000块钱
那这笔钱什么时候去退呢?这笔钱退的会比店铺保证金快,活动结束以后,只要你的活动
在周期间订单没有任何违规的情况下,15天就可以申请解冻提现
所以活动保证金的资金周转效率还是非常高的,那缴纳活动保证金的路径呢,其实是和店铺保证金是一样的
我们在打开商家后台,有一个点击资金管理,这里会有一个保证金
活动保证金,左边是店铺保证金,右边是活动保证金,直接点击充值就可以了
最后呀,我还是需要给大家强调一下
我们要有三个需要逼的坑,都是非常血淋淋的教训
第一就是我们千万不要抱有侥幸的心理违规
因为之前我们就有遇到过有一个商家因为商品描述不符合去判定的违规
不仅店铺会被限制,店铺保证金会被罚
然后包括我们的活动保证金也都会被罚
还有就是商家因为物流延迟被误判虚假轨迹,保证金也会被动
所以在我们平台经营的过程中,一定要遵守规则,有问题的话及时和平台去沟通
第二点,就是别混淆金额的档位
之前有朋友说保证金2000元,其实大多数是普通类目店保证金
那活动保证金的话,默认我们是希望大家能交到5000块钱的
报名前一定要看清楚活动业的要求,别因为少交而导致报名失败
那第三点的话就是要定期检查活动的状态
平台会根据你店铺的月成交金额去调整基础保证金的金额
如果成交金额上涨了,保证金没有及时补交,也可能会被限制,上新,提现,甚至是影响活动报名的资格
那么最后我们去做一下总结
店铺保证金是开店必备的押金,按雷幕取交,可退可解冻
活动保证金是活动报名的担保金,按虚交,活动结束,快速解冻
15天内,两者都是需要足额交,合规用才能避免资金损失和店铺受限
最后本期的视频内容就到这里,咱们下期见